[Music]
and so
the man who attacked dave chappelle
will not be charged with a felony that's
crazy yay
no wait what well the specific felony
like the uh armed uh assault or whatever
yeah so assault with a deadly weapon
right battery because he had uh we
talked about that like he had a gun but
it was a knife yeah did he have it
pulled when he attacked him no tackle i
guess but sometimes they still charge
you if you're in possession of it though
like you don't have to brandish it or
hold it up but if you commit a crime and
it's on you they'll put that on you yeah
not in this state the la district
attorney exactly has decided not to
press charges for a felony he's being
charged with four misdemeanors instead
um and so a lot of people are just sort
of wondering if that's justice because
you know this is dave chappelle he was
attacked like on stage everyone saw it
does this make it kind of okay for this
sort of behavior to have keep attacking
comedians keep jumping on stage if you
get a misdemeanor it's really not that
bad as far as what you have to deal with
it's not that bad maybe they're weighing
it against how they they assume there's
going to be an upcoming civil suit from
both dave chappelle and the hollywood
bowl and the companies that run the
event or something so they're just like
he's going down from these three
entities anyway and he got his arm
[ __ ] busted but that's the a dropping
the going from felony to misdemeanor
it's a clear assault that happened in
front of everyone and as an example it's
like they should [ __ ] show that
they're gonna punish this person for
doing that yeah but knowing america
though because this guy got his [ __ ]
arm like this he's going to sue them and
he's going to win yeah
that arm was funny and he had a big old
like right like that's that's some
regular american [ __ ] right to be like
he won the [ __ ] lawsuit crazy to
think that if this was at dave
chappelle's house dave chappelle might
be getting sued
that's true
right because we're america yeah and he
came and [ __ ] somebody like if he came
into his house kick dave chappelle or
whatever or in california you're saying
oh yeah yeah in california yeah
california um what the [ __ ] is happening
to california dude
man but this does lead me to beg the
question because we do have someone in
this room
who
is a fighter trained fighter oh don't
talk to me about yeah i'm you know my my
skills definitely i'm talking to you if
i want to talk to somebody about how to
get punched in the [ __ ] mouth i guess
i guess you could talk to me about that
you could talk to me about that too i am
an expert at that yeah yeah no but so
what i one of my favorite things about
having nick here is nick knows like you
know fights and like he's honestly
predicted a bunch of usc fights before
they happen we should we never gambled
on it
so nick we should have gambled on it if
you had to attack dave chappelle what
would you do
what am i trying to do am i trying to do
as much bodily attacker if you had to be
the attacker how did this guy [ __ ] up
and what would you have done
okay so let's just watch the video like
this yeah
so from
the initial attack he jumps out right so
did he jump out from like first front
stage
over here i've actually never seen this
clip oh there he is i saw that one yeah
this one so he must have paid a lot of
money to be in front of stage right
that's what the problem was right he
tried to hit him with a spear okay
that's what he tried to do he tried to
run and tackle him but
he like he just didn't grab a leg spears
are more for sure okay yeah like he
didn't try to grab his legs and actually
like finish like a takedown if that's
what he's trying to do yeah that's why
part of me feels like he just wanted
some [ __ ] attention you know like
does he just want to like tackle him
because there was no real plan of attack
yeah if he really wanted to like but he
also doesn't hurt him know how to fight
like yes people don't know how to but
but why is that your first instinct if
you really want to go run up on somebody
you would go up and swing on them right
i think that would be the normal
reaction especially if you're an average
i think most people that don't know how
to fight just tackle you know like
yeah when you see people fight at the
beach or wherever like they they swing
and immediately it's like some like
like fest but if i'm trying to blindside
somebody yes dave chappelle in
particular if i'm trying to go up and i
want to do like i want to hurt this
muffler yeah you're trying to get dave
chappelle i'm going to run up and tr
like in my head i'm going to try to
[ __ ] punch him in the face right i
think that's i think that's a normal
instinct okay like i wonder if jamie
fogg is the one that [ __ ] up his arm
dude right isn't that funny to think
about it could have been chris rock
punching somebody for a chance could
have been buster rhymes doing it too
plus the rhymes probably he's big dude
dude everyone beat the [ __ ] out of that
guy but i don't know i think it was a
shitty uh takedown a shitty tackle
attempt not a good move he he reached
too far you know he jumped too early so
what do you do you it's it's your job to
take dave chappelle down am i me or am i
that guy you're this guy you're you've
got to think about dave chappelle how do
we get into the [ __ ] ground how do we
finish this thing
man he
i don't think this guy has the skills to
take down dave chappelle okay i'll be
honest but it's you you're in his corner
you're trying you're teaching him what
to do he's in slow motion so he goes
does it pull behind the knees i'll say
this you don't jump and reach off the
floor i'll say that like you don't why
not because you want to be able to grab
somebody and then push from the floor
and drive them to the ground so you
don't because
once yeah once you're mid air you don't
have the ground contact to be able to
yeah to drive and really take somebody
down so by jumping and leaping
and you're feeding her midair that's it
you hit a [ __ ] brick wall and that's
it because dave smells a big guy yeah a
big guy and he's all buff now yeah i
mean i'm lifting so if i really want to
take somebody down i'm running i'm
keeping my feet on the floor and i'm
gonna finish that tackle push off before
with my feet instead of like
dying in the air
exactly that makes more sense and that's
why he [ __ ] didn't finish it yeah
that's why this guy sucks that's why i
got beat up yeah because my guys aren't
broken i kind of hope that all of dave
chappelle's homies chris rock jamie foxx
all kind of got a little stomping just
because i feel like when when you're a a
celebrity or a comedian or whatever and
someone out the crowd could ruin your
show and try to hurt you that's like
physically heckling i feel like as as
any performer you guys are on that
performer's side you know like we all
know like the the one heckler that's
trying to ruin the show or make it about
them or whatever so i feel like all of
them just immediately like related to
dave my man [ __ ] this [ __ ] and
they want to protect that [ __ ]
yeah they all love this guy and who
doesn't love dave schmidt did anybody uh
say what his intention was
to to knock out this mixtape do you want
to sell his mixtape okay uh so did you
guys hear the quote afterward
that's now circulating jamie foxx [ __ ]
me up no no
um foxx
he's the cover of the book he's like
this picture and it says jb fox [ __ ]
me up
so recently um very recently
chris uh chris rock and dave chappelle
worth the comedy store on the sunset
strip right and there was a lot of
celebs there like like um kim k diddy
jeff ross and chris rock
obviously chris joined dave on stage and
they joked about both being attacked
during a performance at one point dave
said at least you got smacked by someone
a repute i got smacked by a homeless guy
with leaves in his hair
that's a funny lie
and then chris's response is i got
smacked by the softest n-word that ever
wrapped oh
that's funny dude because
chris
chris rock and will smith's like that
was for sure way more humiliating than
this one for yeah way more because one's
a crazy person another one's another
legend and he wasn't even successful at
it and and chris rock had to just take
it and still hold his like
professionalism and continue the show
you know what i mean and the dude won an
award afterwards yeah jamie foxx didn't
beat up will smith after and even on and
even online there's so many people that
took will smith's sides again i'm like
what tiffany hatters did
yeah they're like oh what what a great
man standing for his wife or like oh
imagine all the stuff that he's been
going through that that had to be
released oh chris yeah he didn't do
anything wrong everybody hates chris
dude that's his whole [ __ ] life will
smith needed those [ __ ] chinese balls
that he could just go like this like a
[ __ ] fire those are fire those are
underrated he needs that [ __ ] rubber
squeezy thing where the ears and the
eyes pop out and [ __ ] like
apparently will smith's not not too uh
foreign with chinese balls if you get
one yeah
that's what people say that's what i
heard it's a rumor it's a famous ellie
rumor
that's a [ __ ] good that's a good burn
really good one and they're coming dude
dave ended his show at the comedy store
with this as he looked over at diddy he
said i'm in the place where you sat in
the car with biggie smalls as he died
adding i hate this city
wow
la
everybody hates l.a huh yeah i mean it's
time to move vegas that's kind of what i
was getting at
that's what this is about it's not about
wait would this have happened in las
vegas no
tupac got shot and died in las vegas
that's true we're gonna edit that out
there is that meme that says tupac faked
his own death to get away from jada
oh yeah i saw that one too
that's gangster
that's okay
you know how like they claimed that they
never [ __ ] right but there was
recently the tupac exhibit in um
hollywood where there's all this like
letters that he wrote and whatever and
one of the letters he wrote a poem for
and it literally says
like i never felt this way for another
woman like i've never [ __ ] anyone this
way the way that we have sex and all the
way we make love all this it's like
literal so i'm like
they never [ __ ] she's lying bro she's
the one that says they never [ __ ]
yeah well that she's the only one left
that's true
on red table talk she said she never
wanted to be married to women
which is [ __ ] wild yo that's so
[ __ ] up man after you have kids and
[ __ ] she says that and then her mom gets
her back on it too like yeah you like i
remember you didn't really want to but
grandma wanted you to whoa was this
after the slap
uh i forgot were they setting the table
for this [ __ ] are they just beating this
man into [ __ ] like dude i don't even
know if these things should be aired out
if this is like how personal it is
he wasn't slapping chris he was slapping
jadah
they're [ __ ] turned around and
slapped chris ross is chilling
whole relationship looks like to me
where you have a stand-up dude that's
just trying his best to be a good
husband and she's just bitter because
she couldn't be the full version of
herself and she's blaming this dude
because it's like
who forced you into the marriage you
didn't have the courage to say no i want
to [ __ ] be single and she could only
talk to red table talk she can't after a
[ __ ] husband he's right there in the
same house oh you know what it was so uh
i think for will
um
she for him he felt that jada turning 40
was going to be a big deal
so i think he spent three years
planning the the party it was like a
film crew and all this stuff and then
when he explained the whole thing and
how much she means to him whatever uh
after he drops that
she tells will no that was just the ego
move to make you feel good
why does she hate him so much whoa i'm
like dude this will spend three years
planning your birthday it's
so weird because it's like this guy they
don't love [ __ ] it's like it's like he
loves her so much and she hates him so
much i don't work their [ __ ] out though
they they don't work their [ __ ] out of
chris ross like jada gijn two and then
will's like
imagine that and then that's the end of
it he never slaps chris isn't it usually
the children's fault when people divorce
yeah it always is actually [ __ ] jaden
jaden jaden
or the children's fault that people
don't divorce and stay together even
though they hate each other don't forget
to like and subscribe and send this
video to a kid who got just had their
parents had got divorced
that was me and my parents got divorced
and it's because of
bart you know the reason why your
parents got divorced yup i did on
purpose
i've been talking hella [ __ ]
dad just come back mom just come back
he played both sides
really good
you